good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about five ways that you
can build a world-class team and as
always as you listen in if there's
something that really resonates with you
make sure to leave it in the comments
below as you're listening put quotes
around it to reinforce it for yourself
and that other people can be inspired as
well if you hire c-level people please
don't be surprised if you have a D level
company if you truly want an iconic
business one that stands the test of the
generations one where you build what I
call a globally cherished brand then you
absolutely must make it your dominant
obsession to hire and manage and retain
and engage only a level performers
I don't hire people who I wouldn't work
for myself I know that's a really good
heuristic because everyone knows this
like there's this saying like a player's
hire a players and B players hire C
players which is like good people hire
good yeah um and I don't think that
that's that informative right because
I'm gonna say like just I'm gonna do
organizations hire better player you
don't get to hire people like I mean no
I mean and but I think a lot of the time
the problem is you don't actually know
and sometimes you're like trying to
figure out how good someone is if you
think they were good you would've hired
them but the heuristic of only hiring
people who you would work for tends to
be pretty good I think because then it's
like then that you know right it's like
I would not work for this person then
okay I'm not gonna like stretch just
because I need to fill a role today hi
Ron mindset not on history
what do I mean by that well when I hire
you know and I still remember reading
Isaacson's biography on Steve Jobs and
they reported Steve Jobs would sit in on
almost every hiring decision look at
Microsoft a Microsoft executive once
said the secret sauce of Microsoft is
not software it's hiring so the second
point which I'm saying is hire on
mindset not history when I hire someone
I am much more interested in their core
beliefs and their primary values because
if there's no belief fit and there's no
values compatibility with our core
values that I'm not interested I mean
some of the core values we've built our
core business on OAD an obsessive
attention to detail if someone is in a
position that requires obsessive
attention to detail and the person we're
looking at the prospect doesn't care
about details they're not going to fit
one of our core business values is AB
daav always be delivering outrageous
value I mean I'm not in this for the
money I'm in this for the love I want to
give 10 times the value to our customers
that they have any right to expect you
come you show up at the Titan summit
every single year you are blown away
the value of the learning and the user
experience that's just the way we play
so when I hire if someone's not all
about generosity and giving they're just
not going to fit so what I'm saying is
we hire on the mindset of the person
rather than on the history I don't
really care too much where they've been
yes we check their record yes we check
their references but I'm more about
mindset core values and ways of
operating if if you are operating at the
level we play at and there's a match
with our values and ways of doing things
I want you on my team we went through
that stage and Apple where we went out
and we thought oh we're gonna be a big
company let's hire professional
management we went out and hired a bunch
of professional management it didn't
work at all most of them were bozos they
they knew how to manage but they didn't
know how to do anything and so what if
you're a great person why do you want to
work for somebody you can't learn
anything from and you know what's
interesting you know me the best
managers are there are the great
individual contributors who never ever
want to be a manager but decide they
have to be a manager because everything
no one else is going to be able to do as
good a job as them we wanted people that
were insanely great at what they did but
work we're not necessarily those
seasoned professionals but who has on at
the tips of their fingers and in their
passion the latest understanding of
where technology was and what we could
do with that technology and who wanted
to bring that to lots of people so the
neatest thing that happens is when you
get a core group of you know 10 great
people they it becomes self-policing as
to who they let into that group so I
consider the most important job of
someone like myself is recruiting the
biggest problem that people have is that
where they should use slow thinking they
use fast thinking and entrepreneurs are
extremely guilty of that as we make
important decisions that have long
potential consequences in Turkey
including affecting the lives of people
and costing money and even leading to
the bankruptcy of a business we make
those decisions with fast thinking when
in reality we should be making them with
slow thinking now I'm a great Drucker
fan as many people are and Mike was
saying
something about hiring the right people
and hiring the right people to work with
you is very important and the biggest
mistakes you make is hiring fast you
hire people quickly the best best
decisions you make are we really take
your time to hire slowly and Peter
Drucker said that fast people decisions
are invariably wrong people decisions
hiring an important person for an
important job has tremendous potential
consequences so therefore you need to
take a long time one of the things I
teach which is in my book how to hire
and keep the best people is a simple
rule that will increase your hiring
accuracy to 90 percent and I've taught
it to Fortune 500 companies and they
make it a rule within their companies to
use Brian's rule yes - this is you
cannot hire except by doing this and I
didn't invent it I just studied the
hiring practices of the companies that
hire the best people and keep them the
longest and they all at the beginning
have a certain process that they follow
and they follow it religiously no
exceptions and so their accuracy in
hiring goes up to 90% or better because
they think more the people you hire
define the culture whether you like it
or not so Larry and Sergey when they
started the company said we need to have
really smart people so they hired a
rocket scientist and they hired a
medical doctor and they hired a Stanford
graduate who had been a professional
football player because they figured
that they wanted normal people who had
done something exceptional so in my case
I was a pilot and I had done other
things and they said okay you're good
enough you know the CEO has to have
something besides being a CEO that makes
them interesting and everyone had
something I would go around I'd say well
what's special about you it's like
what's like Sesame Street you know
what's special about you and what's
special about you but there was always
an interesting story
so another lesson I learned is that you
don't hire generic people you hire
people who've had some kind of stress or
achievement or whatever the best people
hired by the way are CFO's who've gone
bankrupt
boy have they been through the war and
on the CFO's I'm the CFO side and the
finance side you want somebody who's not
gonna happen again and you only go
bankrupt once by the way so when I think
about this topic I think it's two things
that come to mind the first one is that
people are motivated not so much by
money in by
perks and yes that helps people get in
the door and if you're looking at a job
you care about how much one you're gonna
make you care about the perks and the
benefits in the vacation time and can
use a company car and all that stuff but
what makes people happy if you look at
any study and what people what makes
people consistently happy it's always
the work that they're doing and so it's
important that people are doing work
that challenges them and that there's a
mission I want to feel like I'm
contributing I don't want to go work at
some job even if I'm making a decent
salary I don't want to go and work there
and just feel like my soul is being
sucked from me daily people want to feel
like they're on a mission like the work
that they're doing is contributing to
some bigger thing and so that's great
and that's on you as an entrepreneur to
share the mission to feel the mission to
live the mission and don't hire someone
just to do programming but you're you
want to hire a programmer who wants to
really feel the mission so now you don't
just get their brains you get the heart
and soul and you'll get much more
productivity out of them tied in to that
point I also think that it's your job to
share the impact that the mission is
having to share the impact that your
work is having especially for the people
who aren't on the frontlines your
programmers your website developers all
the people who are helping manufacturing
whatever product or service you have
they don't necessarily get to see the
customers and all the glorious things
that you get you're the entrepreneur you
get the interviews you get the
compliments you deal with a lot of the
crap too but you see all the good stuff
that happens and that's juiced and fuel
to keep you going share that with your
team let the programmer know the amazing
results that are coming back not just in
sales but the reaction of people knowing
that the work that they did that day
contributed to somebody being really
happy and saying thank you knowing that
their work had a significant impact on
somebody else's life that's the juice
for them too and so it's on you to share
it with them the second thing that comes
to mind when thinking about building a
world-class team is they want to work
with other people who are at the same
level in what they do
business is a team sport you can only do
so much yourself and if you have that
powerful mission you need to bring on a
team to help you go off and you know go
chase that goal and have the impact that
you're after and you can't do it alone
you can't do it by yourself and one of
the worst feelings in the world is doing
so much work doing so much heavy lifting
and then your teammates drop the ball if
you look at basketball you've got LeBron
James best basketball player in the
world how much would it suck for him to
go down the core beat three defenders do
the craziest move and then pass it to
his teammate who's got a wide open shot
the guy jumps and misses it's crazy
frustrating I just did all this work I'd
beat three guys I poured my heart and
soul into it gave you an easy shot and
you dropped the ball that sucks
now in a sport like basketball LeBron
can just decode those three guys and
slam dunk it on his own in a team sport
like business
you can't solo carry everything all the
time you need to be able to trust that
your teammates will pick you up and
they'll take this awesome thing that you
made and go run with it so if I'm a
programmer or designer or doing some of
the backend work and I put so much love
into making this amazing thing and then
I hand it off and the marketing team
sucks errs mediocre doesn't promote it
or drops the ball I'm gonna feel
terrible I'm gonna feel like all that
work I did was for nothing was
meaningless was useless and I'm not
gonna want to work at your company
anymore and so making sure that you
surround yourself with other great
people so that that one great person
doesn't feel like they're all alone
surrounded by people who are incompetent
I feel is also super important
so you've heard for some of the experts
you've heard my opinions as well we made
this video because easy money sniper
asked me to so if there is a video that
you'd like me to cover in the next
edition of believe life let me know
leave it down in the comments and I'll
see what I can do I'd also love to know
what did you think of the video what did
you learn what lessons you're gonna
apply now to your company that maybe you
didn't know before what's the single
best piece of advice that you've learned
from this video leave it in the comments
I'm gonna join in the discussion finally
I want to give a quick shout out to
Victor McClure which Victor thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
really really means a lot to me those
are you watching you want a chance at a
shout out in the future video make sure
to got a copy of the book and email in
your receipt so we can keep track thank
you again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe and
whatever your one word is I'll see you
soon
and very good at hiring because I've
made a lot of mistakes I learned to look
at the specific individual and look for
the most important traits in them and
ignore everything else especially the
resume sends you in the wrong direction
I learned through trial and error what
makes a great manager what makes a great
salesperson and that's who I always hire
if you're going to hire a lot of
salespeople for your organization I
found that I look for the same three
things in every single person I hired I
wanted someone who was insecure with
something to prove if somebody walks in
they're cocky they never become your
great salespeople my top ten salespeople
making millions of dollars a year every
year came to my office in December
swearing they would never have another
good year why it was ridiculous but they
were insecure enough to think it could
never happen again you want an insecure
person if you're hiring a salesperson
with something to prove you also want
someone who has a positive attitude in
every way because you know what happens
a positive person when they get hit and
sales is all about getting hit and
knocked down they spend very little time
feeling sorry for themselves they get
right back up they're back out you
almost need a low IQ like hit me again
hit me again hit me again that's a great
salesperson and then you need the work
ethic to go with it nobody is great and
sale unless they work like crazy so
those are the three traits I look for in
every great salesperson what I look for
in a manager is someone who's gonna be
loyal I mean heck I'm gonna build a
giant house which is my business on a
shaky foundation how far am I gonna get
I need a structure where the footing as
loyal as can be is gonna stand there
through the thick and thin I also need
someone who believes that we're gonna
succeed
I need someone with the positive
attitude always a positive attitude
because you know what I find I find a
manager with a positive attitude is
always gonna find a way to get to where
you want them to go a mark of a good
manager is someone who's organized I
always ask everyone I'm interviewing in
and
you on a scale of one to ten how would
you rate yourself as an organized person
I never hire anyone who says 9 or 10 I
want the guy who's as old about a 12 a
manager without follow-through is
useless you got to be able to give the
command they get it done and they don't
forget about it when something distracts
them a manager always follows through as
a interview question because we
obviously can't tell people what we're
doing so we want something that has
artificial intelligence maybe has some
comms problems with it it has to really
have these meaty hard like get dirty in
the world kind of stuff because all the
things that we do have those
characteristics I have often asked
people a question about let's say that
we have robotic moles and we're sending
them out in the world they're supposed
to go find gold and bring it back to us
and then just engage them in a
conversation about like how would we do
gold detection how far do you think one
of those moles could dig before I had to
come back and get power do you think
it'd be realistic to like put a tether
on it so that it wouldn't run out of
power you know should we have conveyer
belts like out its butt so that it could
like send the gold back and just keep
digging you know what would happen at
that more like went like under you know
the ground into Canada or Mexico like
what if one of the moles goes rogue you
know what are we gonna do and you very
quickly get into this state where you
find out who's gonna go with you on
these journeys because some people just
kind of short circuit and minute two of
the questions they're just like I know
is over II they don't know it yet for
another 28 minutes but some people are
super excited and they're like wait I
actually think we could do that and you
know it's probably we shouldn't be
making moles going digging for gold we
aren't don't get excited but if you find
one please return it
but the people take the gold out of its
mouth exactly oh they don't like that
but the people who will engage in that
conversation
that's a good sign I think the second
thing is you have to hire bank and big I
don't mean famous
I mean ahead of where you are so when
you're growing an organization really
quickly what happens is that what
normally takes an organization years
happens in a period of just months so
when I was at Google you know my team
went from four to four thousand in about
five years that means that if you look
at those first four people I hired in
order for them to be part of the people
who are running that organization they
need to do about you know 10 or 15 years
worth of growing and you know getting
experience in a much shorter period of
time so if you think you're gonna grow
quickly hire for what you think you're
gonna need over hire hire people who are
more qualified have more experience or
hire people who are right out of school
but can over achieve in their current
roles I don't think it's that number of
years in the workforce that matters I
think it's hiring the people that you're
gonna need then now because then happen
so quickly I may give you one quick
system you got this is a system that
involves people okay one of the most
valuable things that I've ever done just
used it recently with with great success
really really helped me out I call it
the daily update right you hire a new
person you set them down on day one and
you say Tony we're gonna be working
together really excited about working
with you I'd like you to do one thing
for me at the end of every workday I'd
like you to send me a daily update send
it to be my email it should take you
five minutes to do ten minutes max if
takes you more than five to ten minutes
you're doing something wrong right in
the daily update I want you to tell me
three things number one what I did today
results I got right number two problems
or challenges that you know came up
remember three questions that I have for
you okay so what I did today results I
got problems and challenges questions
right if you will watch someone's daily
updates every day for 30 days you will
learn so much about them that people
have known them for years
don't even realize because you will see
the pattern right I'm a results-driven
are the activity driven do they even you
know notice the difference in their life
noticing whether or not they're really
even asked any new questions whether
they're getting curious about things in
any new way shape or form what is
perceived by them to be a problem versus
exactly what they ask you if they have a
problem you know what's what's going on
and really great even even more
importantly do they send it to you every
day because absolutely right when you
get to the end of the first 30 days and
they got 12 of them or six exactly there
are a couple of scenarios one is they
sent it every day but it's bad news yeah
one is they send every day that it's
good news another is they didn't send it
every day that's bad news and others
they you know dinners whatever so
they're kind of these options if you've
got someone that's performing it
actually doesn't matter whether they
sent them every day or not there I'm
there a performer yeah if there's a
superstar and they didn't send the daily
update every day you can say we're gonna
get you an assistant that's gonna send
your updates every day okay fine just
tell me maybe you can coalition or
whatever right but if they're not
performing and they're not sending daily
updates or they're not performing and
sending - you'll see it and I mean in my
experience the underperformance they
usually don't send the update every day
and then when you sit down at with them
at the end of 30 days you can just say
look I asked you to do one thing
consistently for this 30 days that's
truly right I ask you to do one thing
and what just send me a little of daily
update and they'll have excuses or
whatever will come up you say I just
don't feel like this is gonna be a good
fit because we need results and
accountability and communication and
it's just not your style to do that you
know you're not then it then it kind of
works out for everybody you know it's in
everybody's best interest so the daily
update has been tremendously valuable to
me love is very important I look for
someone who loves the company who loves
a vision that you're casting I'm casting
loves a crusade that that their heart
starts connecting with it because if you
can hire my experience has been if you
can hire people based on love you don't
need to have work ethic on a list
because love is an action in my opinion
if love is an action
the definition of love to you is also an
action it's a verb then that means
everything from love work ethic comes
because of love so if someone loves
they're gonna have a work ethic if
parents make food for their kids three
meals a day not because they have to but
because they love and they put the time
to cook if you know parents put the time
to drop off the kids in the morning and
pick them up and work so hard and do
this and do that love it doesn't there's
no manual that says you got to work hard
when you're a parent no the manual is
you'll love they have a place in your
heart so you work so I hire based on
love so and another thing would love is
this as what to keep in mind I don't I
can't force somebody to love you your
vision your company can do it and if you
constantly are trying to force somebody
to love you it's kind of like the guy
who's in love with this girl and he
loves her so much but she doesn't love
him she likes him and you know she
tolerates him and all his life he's
trying to earn her love and she's just
not gonna love him she doesn't love him
she just likes him you know they're just
together cuz it's good they don't this
guy has all his life and that can be
very draining
I don't hire for forcing somebody to
love if you love it we're gonna work to
get if you don't no problem you're gonna
find a place that you're gonna love and
we're gonna find people that we're gonna
hired are we gonna love this one that's
okay